on a basketball court the world-famous
nicknames set it all he was like the
Pied Piper players followed his lead and
his lead was always right but his drive
to succeed didn't stop on the court
Irvin Magic Johnson
the giant point guard with the MVP smile
and no-look pass with a ball in his
hands magic seemed to see everything his
vision went beyond the game to becoming
a playmaker in the world of business but
one thing no one saw coming was this man
I know this can't be this can't be I
didn't want him to die people don't
realize how hard that was for even a
quick playing basket that's all he did
all his life he used it as a rallying
point to go to an even higher level in
his life and he chose business as the
platform to do it but it wasn't easy
magic had to reinvent himself from
scratch and the learning curve was steep
many people said doing what you're doing
magic demonstrates that you are a
tremendously gifted basketball player in
a dumb business manner
it's not real life telling people that I
was going to be successful investing in
urban America and then proving
[Music]
in the fall of 2011
Magic Johnson made a surprise visit to a
homecoming pep rally at his former high
school in Lansing Michigan
[Music]
[Applause]
look it doesn't matter where you are
financially I grew up poor but I didn't
have war dreams you can have two dreams
basketball was there and I think his own
dream was being the great businessman he
can sniff out a good deal and know a
good deal from the bad one just like he
can no work pass the basketball
Irvin had a belief that the urban
marketplace was a rich entrepreneurial
venue you have to understand your
purpose not only here at Everett high
school but your purpose in life the
extraordinary life of Earvin Magic
Johnson began on August 14th 1959 in
Lansing Michigan one of ten kids he grew
up in a working-class african-american
neighborhood on Lansing's West Side
Irving's mother Christine was a school
custodian his father Irving senior
worked at GM on the assembly line in 30
years at the plant he missed a shift
just twice despite holding down two
full-time jobs people often ask me who
did you allies growing up and I always
say the first person is my father
everything I do now in life I do it the
right way it's all because of him and
what he instilled in me
when Ervin was about five his parents
bought him a basketball it was love at
first touch I would take my basketball
everywhere I went my mom wanted me to go
to the corner store and get some milk
and a loaf of bread
I would dribble that basketball all the
way there then if the school bus left at
seven o'clock in the morning I would be
out there at six o'clock at the
playground before the bus left working
on my game my neighbors used to say man
I see this little boy come inside my
house with this basketball does he sleep
with me daddy with by the time he was in
junior high Irvin was a local star but
his dad didn't cut him any slack the two
worked together on Irvine seniors
weekend trash hauling business and one
winter morning mr. Johnson taught his
son a lesson that stayed with him for
the rest of his life some trash were
froze in the ground and he just ripped
off the top and so I just come around
and told get out of the truck come on
I'll show you how to do this he grasped
me and drags me in the snow back to
where the barrels were and he said you
know what Ervin if you do this job
halfway you're gonna practice halfway as
a basketball player you're gonna do your
homework and be a student that is only
putting in half the effort and I was
like wow so I want you to go get this
shovel and chop the ice and get the
paper that stuck in that ice and dump it
on the truck just then my work ethic
went off the chart because I became a
perfectionist then
Irving was bused to predominantly white
Everett high school in 1973 his new
teammates initially tried to freeze him
out of the offense but six-foot-seven
with the ball handling skills of a point
guard he quickly emerged as the leader
of the team and after dominating the
game with 36 points 18 rebounds and 16
assists a local reporter gave him a
nickname somebody's already called dr. J
somebody has the name biggie I want to
call you magic and I just start giggling
again you know and I'm hitting my boys
like is he serious
I never thought in my wildest dreams
that people would really call me magic
but I have to admit it fit my game and
my personality the flashy nickname never
got in the way of Magic's willingness to
work on or off the court he held down a
pair of jabs clerking in a convenience
store and cleaning the offices of two
african-american businessmen I didn't
know african-americans owned buildings
and car dealerships and things of that
nature so when I met Greg Eaton and Joe
Ferguson they helped me to say you know
what you should also dream about being a
businessman sometimes while Ervin was
cleaning the office building his dreams
took over and I would bust in like I was
the CEO I would recline the seat put my
feet up on the desk and I'll pretend I
had an assistant out front I hit the
intercom button and said you know Tony
can you bring me the coffee and
doughnuts in the day's paper
Gregory Eaton who currently owns the
largest ground transportation service in
Michigan walked in on Irvine in the
middle of his daydream he says well
we're gonna do this and I'm a plan there
said you know I'm Melana off for I need
more people to work and I start laughing
you know I came in a room here that big
spawn he said said Gregory I've just
being you
meanwhile magics other dream was taking
off
as a senior he led Everett to the state
championship in the flush of victory
MAGIX high school coach George Fox gave
him a heads up my said Earvin there's
somebody else in this country today
that's got skills just like you and he
might not work you and he might be
better Larry Bird was that guy next year
will attend admissions Day University at
Michigan State
magic continued to shine and in his
sophomore year the Spartans made it to
the NCAA finals where they faced Indiana
State and that guy Larry Bird
it was the most heralded championship
showdown of all time and magic who had
the better supporting cast was dominant
somehow we waived the win that game and
I always mention that to him yeah Larry
I got that one over you
[Laughter]
the Los Angeles Lakers made
nineteen-year-old Magic Johnson the
NBA's number one draft pick in the
summer of 1979 magic signed a five-year
contract with a package worth about five
hundred thousand dollars a year but the
highest-paid rookie with a five-year
three point two five million dollar
contract with the Celtics was yep
that other guy Larry Bird teaming up
with superstar center Kareem
abdul-jabbar
magic helped lead the Lakers to the NBA
Finals against Philadelphia in his first
year the Lakers were up three games to
two but in Game five Kareem rolled an
ankle on the flight to Philly the team
was demoralized I went in sat in Kareem
seat and said never fear magic is here
and the guys looked like they started
laughing I said let me tell you guys
something I'm not going all the way five
hours to Philadelphia to lose to the
76ers and I said guess who's gonna play
center and they said well who me
magic was phenomenal scoring 42 points
hauling down 15 rebounds dishing out
seven assists and leading the Lakers to
the championship Michael Cooper was a
Los Angeles Laker between 1978 and 1990
we all became a believer after that game
that this kid here could get it done and
well you know what he wasn't a kid
anymore he was a man cuz he grew up
during that game he showed us that he
could lead us to many many more
championships to make sure of that Laker
owner Jerry Buss signed magic to the
biggest longest contract extension in
NBA history a 25 million dollar deal
that would keep him a Laker for 25 years
I was stunned my father was just they
actually got that much money in the
world I just said you know I'm gonna do
something good with this money I'm not
going to blow it
inspired by his mentor's magic started
looking for investment opportunities
when he heard about a chance to buy a
radio station in Denver at a bargain
price he sensed an opportunity it was a
gut feeling like the kind magic often
had on a basketball court he offered his
teammates a chance to join him in the
deal they looked at me like I was crazy
so I went and raised the money anyway
and each of us made about a million
dollars off of the station and I said
yes so I took the check to the locker
room and showed the guys right then they
found out that I knew business his
teammate Kareem abdul-jabbar on the
other hand did not have the same
instincts in 1986 making two million
dollars a year abdul-jabbar faced
financial disaster charging his business
manager with mismanaging millions of
dollars for magic it was a wake up call
about taking care of his own finances he
feel very bad because he was crazy about
Kareem most of America is in Dubrow and
he learned from that I said I can't let
this happen to me so I got to get rid of
everybody and get me the right people in
place and I got a really sign all my own
checks all of that magic also took
control of business on the court in 1984
he made his fourth trip to the NBA
Finals this time against none other than
the Boston Celtics and Larry Bird too
many fans and the media it became more
than just a basketball game David Stern
has been NBA commissioner for 28 years
the lunch pail Brigade with one Hall of
Fame team on the Celtics and the
Showtime guys from LA and the clash of
styles some made it into the Clash of
Civilizations
he had two of the greatest players that
play the game one black one white and
they were going up against each other
head-to-head magic transcended race as
did Larry you had that ability didn't
matter whether you were white or black
the riveting series culminated in a game
showdown but it was not magics night in
fact he blew some key plays and lost
embarrassingly it was his first real
failure on the court basketball legend
Jerry West was the Lakers general
manager at the time here's a guy that
carried the team here's a guy that got
us there in one game
besides worthy of the hero of the bum
the last thing he said is damn Larry got
me this one and that bothered him I said
in the dark the whole summer in my house
I didn't go outside that much I put my
whole life into working out because I
had to redeem myself it didn't take long
magic and Larry faced off again in the
finals the following year and magic and
his Lakers finally got their first ever
win over the subjects that was that
happiest guy Larry I enjoyed every
minute of an 85 watching you walk to
your car but your head down and upset so
I got him back Magic celebrated during
the off-season by focusing on his other
passion business he asked legendary
super agent Michael Ovitz to help him
learn the ropes but ovince said no I was
incredibly direct with them about what I
thought about handling athletes how
difficult it was and I said we're just
not going to get into the sports
business even with you I went in 69 and
I think I went out five nine you know it
was the first time magic didn't matter
but magic didn't give up he started
calling me every other day
and he came in and he said look I heard
what you said I want you to make an
exception and I want to learn he said
what part of the newspaper do you read
first and I said of course the sports
page he said if you're gonna be a
businessman you got to be the business
section first Wall Street Journal
announcer time Bloomberg and then I laid
out for him that it would be like going
to graduate school and did he want that
on his plate everything looked me in the
eye and said I will do it and I said I
will tell Ovitz his mentoring quickly
paid off
in 1988 with the NBA soaring in
popularity magic realized that the
league was making multi millions
licensing players names on t-shirts
while the players only got a small slice
of the proceeds he wasted no time
confronting commissioner David Stern who
said the league owned all licensing so I
said okay I'm all set out then I said it
doesn't make sense I'm gonna call Larry
and tell him to set up so commissioner
wait are you talking about you kids oh
he said okay
this is what I do you can become a
licensee of the NBA to this day Stern
won't talk about the details of his deal
with magic that's confidential
information
we were looking for ways to help magic
and we were also looking to help
ourselves the most important part of it
was that magic was beginning to get a
real sense for himself magic became the
first active NBA player to have his own
licensing deal when the Lakers won
another championship later that year
magic says he sold 150,000 t-shirts in
only four days now he was thinking
beyond basketball and he was thinking
big I want to own everything in Los
Angeles I want on this that Bissonnette
and buildings and recording I want to be
the first black owner and the NBA
something else clicked for magic as the
Laker bus rolled through decaying black
neighborhoods in cities like Chicago
Atlanta and Detroit I'm seeing vacant
buildings vacant houses and so much
blight in the urban community and I was
really disturbed by that Cory Johnson is
an editor at large for Bloomberg
Television Magic saw the black community
fall apart or real he's fallen real hard
times in his lifetime but he remembered
what it was like when it worked when a
white CEO drives through south central
to see black people when magic droves to
south central he saw diversity and he
saw opportunity it planted a seed for me
to invest my money into urban America
once I started my company that's what I
wanted to do invest in her
but before magic could do anything to
bring urban deadzones back to life he
would have to face his own devastating
crisis
[Music]
you
October 25th 1991 three-time League MVP
Magic Johnson was suddenly called back
to Los Angeles from a preseason road
game for a meeting with the Los Angeles
Lakers team doctor I'm sitting in dr.
melman's office and he begins to tell me
that I had HIV and just I was just
devastated I said okay so what does that
mean for you know I'm gonna die magics
thoughts race to his wife cookie they
had been married less than two months
and she was pregnant I had to sit her
down and tell her she began to cry I
said you know I can I can understand if
you want to leave you know
and just as I said leave she smacked me
so hard and she said you know we're
gonna do this together we're gonna beat
this together she found out a few days
later that she was okay the baby was
okay and then I said okay now I can deal
with me magic shared the news with his
friends and teammates and then he got a
call he would never forget from his old
rival Larry Bird he spoke about it years
later in an HBO special was some happens
and then he find out who really your
friends are and people who really care
about you despite a toxic atmosphere
around HIV and AIDS magic decided to go
public his decision surprised everyone
maybe just should go to Mexico go
somewhere mom he said I can't thank you
I can't go into place he said I have to
stand up and I have to you know be the
man that you and dad taught me to be and
go before the people or let them know I
told them we got to make it better for
the world because if I don't come out
then this disease will go on and keep
spreading magic made a gut-wrenching
announcement that is burned in
everyone's memory because of the HIV
virus that I have attained I will have
to retire from the Lakers today it
instantly made him the new face of HIV
and AIDS I'm a missed plane and I will
now become a spokesman for the HIV virus
he handled that with so much grace and
flair and as an adult man look magic was
his set here for different reasons and
he was given an opportunity to show us
what he could do on and off the floor
magic was honest about how he got HIV
unsafe sex with many different partners
just like that
nearly 12 million dollars worth of
endorsements for history along with his
basketball career
[Music]
[Applause]
but the fans didn't disappear they rally
to aside by voting him into the 1992
all-star game he turned in a stunning
MVP performance
and later in the year he won a gold
medal with the Olympic dream team
but he couldn't walk away from the
thrill of the game less than a year in
retirement magic floated the idea of a
comeback but some of his superstar
friends like Karl Malone refused to play
with him on the court I think he felt
like frankly a kind of a pariah where
some of the things said all he wanted to
do was play basketball compete but they
never looked at in the same way again we
had to educate our players we had to
educate our public we were dealing with
a combination of ignorance and fear
after I had gone to the Olympics and I
was thinking about returning to the NBA
a lot of guys came out against me I know
all the things that I've been going
through with HIV I think that really
hurt me but for magic the game was over
he traded in his jersey for a
double-breasted suit and tie and began
laying the groundwork for a business
career he bought a 4.5% ownership stake
in the Lakers for a reported 10 million
dollars and he formed the Magic Johnson
Development Corporation which he hoped
would make him a big winner in a new
kind of game and I thought I had to do
it sooner and faster because I didn't
know how much time I had you always who
are concerned about ok is am I gonna be
here is HIV gonna turn into AIDS this is
a man who could have called it a day and
disappeared Tim lime Rickey is president
and CEO of sports venue giant AEG and
instead what he did is he used it as a
rallying point to go to an even higher
level in his life and he chose business
as the platform to do it
you
[Music]
the riots that swept through Los Angeles
in April 1992 turned much of South
Central LA into a wasteland John Mac is
the former head of the Los Angeles
Chapter of the Urban League the
community at that point was devastated
in so many ways there were no
supermarkets people have to travel long
distances to be able to see a movie the
community was demoralized Magic Johnson
looked at South LA and saw opportunity
people they got a drive outside their
community to spend their disposable
income if I just put it right in front
of them they're gonna come it's common
sense
especially to movies minorities would
have number one group of people going to
the movies at that time but we had no
theaters in our community there were no
first-run theaters in South LA because
investors who didn't know the area saw
it as a war zone riddled with gang
violence ken Lombard was president of
the Johnson Development Corporation from
1992 to 2004 we were asking them to come
in and help us build a business in
locations that most of them were
uncomfortable with driving in the
response was no investors were not ready
to invest in urban America they couldn't
see how that they could get their return
on investment
Lewis G Feldman is chair of the Los
Angeles office at goodwin Proctor LLP
and a partner in the firm's real estate
group many people said doing what you're
doing magic demonstrates that you are a
tremendously gifted basketball player in
a dumb businessman magic and his partner
Ken Lombard were determined to prove
them wrong they wanted to build a
multiplex in Baldwin Hills a largely
middle-class neighborhood with over 1
million people in a five-mile radius
Peter Guber
then head of Sony Pictures agreed to a
meeting he wanted to tell me about a
country far off not too far off though
he told us about a land where there was
a great theater going audience I mean
unbelievable they loved movies and they
also spoke English and that land was
six miles away in Baldwin Hills was the
african-american community in early 1995
Sony agreed to partner with magic as
long as he put up half the money two
point five million dollars according to
magic as a way of making sure he stayed
personally involved
halfway through construction local
gangbangers shut the project down this
was the moment of truth what investors
had feared the most magic and Lombard
faced the crisis head-on they showed up
35 strong man's you're gonna I had six
guys with us and we had a conversation
that frankly if I never have again in
life it would be too soon it was
dramatic no question about it I think
that any time you put gang members in a
situation you think wow okay what's
going to happen you know magic agreed to
put ten bloods and ten Crips on the
construction crew in exchange he laid
down ground rules to ensure that the
theaters would be violence free
essentially said no gang colors this is
neutral territory most theaters don't
necessarily dive that deep into into the
the inner workings of the community but
for us to be successful we had if magic
had not been successful with those
theaters the resistance that he would
have experienced would have been
tremendous it's no second chance at a
first impression everything was riding
on the success of the Magic Johnson
theater you know this is not a charity
thing with the gang troops worked out
magic now faced the next challenge
pulling in an audience his solution to
customize or majus eyes his theaters for
the south-central community right down
to the concessions we're flavour of
people who grew up on kool-aid so you
gotta have strawberry soda grape soda
orange soda we got to have a spicier
sausage than everybody else so we
actually changed a lot of the menu to
fit the demographics of the community
the night before the opening magic
called the Sony food buyer to make sure
he had enough hot dogs on hand he said
look you got enough for a month the same
amount that we give the suburban
theaters you're gonna get we sold out
all the hot dogs that normally takes 30
days now to sell out in suburban America
we sold them out in one night what you
didn't know
but I knew minorities we're not gonna go
to dinner in a movie we're gonna have
dinner right in the movies that's why we
gonna sell so many hotdogs Kawana Brown
was the fourth employee hired by Magic
Johnson enterprises and is currently the
company's CEO Oh everyone came out to
celebrate this monumental opening
because it was more than a theater the
community felt as if someone cares and
they recognize that there is an
opportunity to develop here what really
made me proud that theater was sitting
there over 15 years no incident no
graffiti on it I had some of the highest
per capita in the industry it was a very
successful theater the Magic Johnson
multiplex
in South LA was a slam-dunk one of the
top grossing theaters in the country
Sony and Magic quickly followed with
theaters in Harlem
Houston Cleveland and Atlanta stunningly
just as his new career was taking off
magic had one more point to make one
more play to run one more game to prove
he wasn't finished
I came down and laid it in aha Oh magic
[Music]
Magic Johnson was back for years after
retiring because of an illness that many
thought would take his life
Magic Johnson now 36 was healthy enough
to once again bring Showtime to LA the
first moment I touched that ball boy I
mean I was actually back I was actually
playing the game that I live he looked
like he'd never been away never missed a
beat he had the same energy you know he
had the same perception when the throw
the ball he threw always to it in the
right place still magic knew he had his
moment despite putting up impressive
numbers he retired for good after the
Lakers failed to advance in the playoffs
at the end of the 1996 season I just
wanted to close the chapter of my
basketball career but I didn't want HIV
to close it I wanted to close it it's
over and I'm happy that it's over with
his wife cookie by his side he spent
much of his time working with the Magic
Johnson foundation to raise awareness
and funds for AIDS and he zeroed in on a
new business idea one that could
potentially put him in every urban
neighborhood in America
driving around la magic noticed
Starbucks on nearly every corner except
South Central he understood that black
people drank coffee too he saw that
Starbuck had a great product and he
thought he could bring something to a
project in the black community we like
to socialize we like to hang so that's
what made Starbucks not only the best
coffee in the world but also a place
where minorities can hang out meet their
friends and just lounge so perfect
perfect situation except for one thing
Starbucks had never partnered with
anyone let alone in places like South LA
he pulled it off in part by picking a
site for the first star books that was
teeming with potential customers the
traffic counts were huge I mean I think
was a in upwards of a million cars per
then drove up and down those streets
literally right by the site they could
not deny that the demographics were
surpassed what their normal standard
criteria was for saying yes to a
location magic brought Starbucks CEO
Howard Schultz to Los Angeles to see
what he was talking about firsthand he
was very impressed with the management
team and how we ran our theaters how
clean it was so sometimes you got to
take your partner or potential partner
to the deal to let them see it for
themselves
Magic Johnson opened his first Starbucks
on April 7 1998 in a South LA shopping
center not far from his movie theaters
in Baldwin Hills once again he majus
eyes we put in soft R&B Motown
we got the Four Tops and Smokey Robinson
you saw peach cobbler or you saw
sockitumi cake it became a place a home
away from home but a home that felt like
Europe magics initial deal with Schultz
gave him 50% ownership of ten Starbucks
they did so well that Schultz gave the
go-ahead for 30 now instead of traveling
outside our community we can spend our
money right here in our own community
and later 125 a lot of the morning I
would actually drive outside and sit in
the parking lot and watch how many
people would go in I would come in early
in the morning to make sure we were
getting the lines out I'm a
detail-oriented guy I am a hands-on guy
I'm a control freak
you
[Music]
five years into his burgeoning career as
an entrepreneur
Magic Johnson tried to work his magic on
a different stage I thought I could be
the black Johnny Carson and a little
didn't work out it didn't work out the
Magic Hour tanked after eight weeks
a rare failure for the Magic Man magic
is now he's not a talker on TV though
magic a doer or if you weren't very good
although the show was a bust it was
great to see Magic looking so healthy
with daily meds and workouts the HIV
virus was deep in remission and he was
brimming with energy his main focus was
raising the kind of investment dollars
that could turn whole minority
neighborhoods around now I got a track
record of success the theaters track
record with Starbucks successful I want
scale now I want to take it to a whole
nother level years earlier magic had
begun to do just that he had gone to
CalPERS the giant pension fund for
California's public employees and
convinced them that investing in
inner-city projects could be profitable
with CalPERS money magic and his
partners bought and renovated the Ladera
shopping center we opened up the
Starbucks from took a closed-down
barbecue restaurant and open up the
magics TGI Fridays within about a year
period of time we had transformed that
Center into one that not only was the
community proud of but that they
supported in droves for the shopping
center for 22 made it a hundred percent
occupied we sold it for about 48 now
magic wanted to launch his own
investment fund one that could pull in
hundreds of millions from investors
willing to bet on the urban market he
partnered with Bobby Turner chairman and
CEO of Canyon Capital Realty Advisors
who thought it would be easy to raise
the money
his capitalization target was 300
million dollars
a sum that canyon thought could be
raised in six months magic knew better
Irvin looked at me and said wow I
thought I was teaming up with a smart
partner Bobby Turner is chairman and CEO
of Canyon Capital Realty Advisors he
knows Bobby this is gonna take two years
to raise a son because institutional
capital believes that urban communities
are lonely worthy of philanthropy for
government spending and they don't
understand the opportunities magic was
right for two years he and Turner criss
crossed the country the pitch was I know
the urban consumer I know what they want
what they need
I've already done a wonderful job of
driving ROI with the theaters and with
Starbucks and I can do the same here
this is just gonna give me a bigger
footprint I can gain scale and I promise
you that the the strategy is sound there
was a lot of people who who said some
tough thing we're never invested over
America you know and right in front of
me you know and why wouldn't we invest
in your people I look down and there was
Bourbons hand on my thigh
ripping with all of his might Ervin took
a deep breath composed himself and
looked at this individual and said what
I can tell you is that when we people
raise our fund
we will not be investing in your
people's communities and that really
epitomized magic grace under fire magic
and Turner's persistence finally paid
off the three hundred million dollar
Canyon Johnson fund launched in 2002
borrowing on the 300 million Canyon
Johnson was able to underwrite 1.5
billion dollars in inner-city projects
housing and commercial ventures in 13
states we thought that that billion
dollars or more was going to provide us
with with really an opportunity to
transform the quality of life and be a
significant tipping point in the right
direction for minority communities
across the country
magic splashes deal was close to home
in 2003 Canyon Johnson decided to gamble
on downtown LA and bought the
Transamerica Center a 32 story office
tower in a sketchy neighborhood not far
from the Staples Center where the Lakers
played 100 million in 200 million out
nice double on leverage and people saw
the light and other people followed he
was a pioneer nobody ever thought in
their wildest dreams that's a Canyon
Johnson fund would purchase the
Transamerica building and that
transaction actually opened the
floodgates for us our second fund took
us two and a half months to raise we
went back to the exact same investors
who invested was in the first fund they
looked at us and said here's six hundred
million dollars fun three literally took
us two and a half phone calls to raise 1
billion dollars no longer were the
canyon Johnson urban funds pioneers we
were the established go-to investor in
the urban market despite the growth
Canyon Johnson's urban investment ride
has not been entirely magical in one of
his investments in Brooklyn community
and union activists attacked Magic for
investing in luxury condos instead of
affordable housing and for not giving
all of his workers union benefits throw
me because first of all I am a union guy
my parents grew up both through the
Union so I love the unions and that
particular building was not a decision
we made we have a management company
that manages those buildings and they
made that decision
that hurts that hurts me personally it
hurts my brand so we had to jump on that
and make sure people understand that
that's not who I am
we do care about our workers and we want
them to have health benefits that's what
it's all about
[Music]
on November 7th 2011
Magic Johnson mark the anniversary of
his gut-wrenching announcement that he
was HIV positive hey I am 20 years later
Wow
what a blessing
I get up about 4:30 in the morning
stretch about 5:00 and then I either run
two or three miles or I do type O not
coming to the office I love the work all
day and night and then I have a great
family
you know cookie is a great wife and
three kids and I have two grandkids now
I got a great life and so that keeps me
going
magic cashed out of his ownership stake
in the LA Lakers and Starbucks in 2010
for an estimated 100 million dollars
according to the Los Angeles Times his
personal net worth is reported to be
half a billion dollars the hall-of-famer
made another big play when he announced
the launch of a new cable television
network aspire that will offer uplifting
images of African Americans combined
with his ownership of vibe magazine and
the TV show Soul Train Magic is poised
to add media mogul to his titles yes he
has made millions and millions of
dollars and I'm happy for him but he has
demonstrated as few others have that you
can do good and do well at the same time
I'm like okay how high can he go he's
gonna keep on going until he's ranked
number one billionaires who doesn't take
magics call that means he could get into
any company any boardroom any chairman
any CEO and at least have a conversation
and when you're sitting there talking to
him one-on-one
good luck saying no to him Los Angeles
Dodgers owner Frank McCourt couldn't say
no to magic when he led a group of
investors and their successful 2.15
billion dollar bid for the historic team
in March 2012 the group including
baseball executive Stan Caston
Guggenheim Partners mark Walter and
longtime friend Peter Guber
paid the largest price tag ever for a
sports franchise magic is now headed to
the owners box he'd be a terrific owner
because he he focuses on a lot of things
but he's not intimidated by I would say
the stardom of the players no matter who
you are if you haven't walked in their
shoes you tend to be intimidated
by celebrity and by stardom that's just
the way it is but not if you're Magic
Johnson even though he's really
successful now I think this paths gonna
be wider I think there's gonna be like a
freeway when he's when he's done magic
success of course has never been defined
entirely in dollars and cents minorities
we are at site still in touch people
because we didn't lie to so much
they haven't been lied to by me see and
they see that and they say we love Him
because he's bringing change in urban
America and I think that those hurts
just said to me Wow job well done kid
and I take it every single time
especially when when I put my heart and
soul and everything that I do and they
know that
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]